There is something electrifying about discovering
an awesome movie.
The plot, characters, and cinematography are
almost enough to judge whether a film is going
to be a dud or a longtime favorite but the
performances are also integral to the overall
quality of a movie.
Even if the film is filled with brilliant
acting, one terrible actor can ruin the rest
of the movie.
Here are 10 Famous Actors Whose Performance
Ruined Their Movies.
Mickey Rooney - Breakfast At Tiffany's
Breakfast at Tiffany’s is a classic film
starring the elegant and graceful Audrey Hepburn.
It is the film that features many iconic moments
including Hepburn adorned in her black dress,
pearls, and elbow length gloves while she
eats a croissant in front of the famous jewelry
store.
While the film certainly took liberties with
Truman Capote’s novella, mostly to appeal
to mainstream audiences and keep the censors
at bay, it was one particular casting decision
that was the most maddening.
Mickey Rooney’s portrayal of Mr. Yunioshi
was just so bizarre that it halts the film
every time he appears.
The casting of a white actor to play a Japanese
character was bad enough but to add prosthetic
teeth to create Japanese caricature was highly
offensive.
Rooney’s performance is also hammy.
As much as the rest of the film is a delight,
Rooney’s performance is disastrous.
Katie Holmes - Batman Begins
The character of Rachel Dawes was just not
a success with two actresses giving it a shot
in two different fims.
Maggie Gyllenhaal was slightly shrill and
lacked chemistry with nearly every actor she
shared the screen with in The Dark Knight,
which was a departure from her usual work.
However, Katie Holmes’s performance was
just bland.
For those viewers who have never seen Holmes
on Dawson’s Creek, you aren’t missing
much since she plays a version of the same
character in everything she’s in.
While her Rachel Dawes may not ruin the film
as much as others on this list, her apparent
boredom certainly detracts from the overall
value of the film.
Diane Keaton, Because I said so
The 2007 romantic comedy Because I Said So
was never going to be a great movie but Diane
Keaton's performance mitigated any possibility
of it being a watchable flick.
Using her tired combination of zany Annie
Hall mixed with a neurotic female Woody Allen,
Keaton forces herself into every scene with
attention seeking gusto, making the film nauseating.
Mandy Moore‘s shtick can get exhausting
after a while too but her scenes with the
charming Gabriel Macht are fun to watch.
Moore’s sisters are played by Lauren Graham
and Piper Perabo, who are both a pleasure
to watch but once Keaton joins in, the movie
falls apart.
Even Stephen Collins who is best known for
his role as the unbearably preachy but well-meaning
father on 7th Heaven, a show with more bad
acting than good, somehow manages to do a
better job than an Oscar winner.
Keaton has proven to be a fine and lovable
actress in previous films, but her work in
Because I said So is just grating.
Hayden Christensen, Star Wars
There is much speculation over whether Hayden
Christensen can act.
This mystery is undoubtedly fueled by his
acting in the Star Wars films, Attack of the
Clones and Revenge of the Sith.
His dry robotic performance supports any theory
that Christensen was not there at all and
he was just computer generated.
Frankly, if he was simply CGI, the character
may have emoted more successfully.
To be fair, Christensen is a decent actor.
Shattered Glass is proof enough, but there
are a handful of other films that prove he
knows what he’s doing.
The worst part of this particularly bad performance
is that it is a vital element of the Star
Wars saga, he is Darth Vader after all.
Russel Crowe, Les Miserables
Russell Crowe is a fine actor and deserves
his multiple Academy Award nominations but
even the most impressive thespians can get
miscast in a film, Les Miserables is that
film.
Since the film is a musical with the actors
singing live, someone probably should have
let Russell Crowe know that he can’t sing.
Hugh Jackman, Anne Hathaway, and Eddie Redmayne
have such incredible singing voices and amazing
acting chops but every time Crowe’s character,
Javert appears on screen, it is time for a
bathroom break.
Russell Crowe’s performance and singing
hinder the film so much that it could be the
reason it lost out for the Best Picture Academy
Award in 2013.
Tommy Lee Jones Batman Forever
In seems nearly impossible to out-chew the
scenery in a film that also features Jim Carrey
but Tommy Lee Jones somehow made it possible
with Batman Forever.
His portrayal of Two -Face, is baffling and
loud.
Obviously, once Gotham’s District Attorney,
Harvey Dent becomes the supervillain, Two-Face,
he may go insane but Jones plays the character
not only bonkers but also incredibly persistent
with roaring his lines.
This is a movie that has Jim Carrey Cackling
as the Riddler, comic explosions, and a blaring
soundtrack by U2 and Seal, and yet it is still
Tommy Lee Jones who is the most deafening
element of Batman Forever.
Linda Fiorentino, Dogma
Linda Fiorentino’s performance in Dogma
ruins the movie not because she is a horrid
actress but because of her inability to realistically
interact with the other actors in the film.
Her character should also be more interesting
than the way she conveys it.
Her monotone monologues feel like she believes
she is in a much more serious film than she
is and her conversations with each character,
and not just Jay and Silent Bob, would make
you believe that her character thinks everyone
around her is beneath her.
Apparently, Fiorentino was exposing her real-life
distaste for the film as writer and director
Kevin Smith has stated that the filming of
Dogma was miserable.
If Smith could have done it over again, he
would have cast Janeane Garofalo in the lead
role rather than relegating her to the minor
role in which she did appear.
Garofalo may have been the perfect fit amongst
the rest of the Kevin Smith regulars and a
vast improvement to Fiolentino.
January Jones, X-Men First Class
After watching January Jones in X-Men: First
Class audiences may be wondering if Jones
attended the Katie Holmes School of Bored
Acting.
Jones is beautiful and her performance in
Mad Men as 1960s housewife Betty Draper is
flawless but her role as Emma Frost seems
like a retread of Betty which makes no sense
for the comic book character.
We can look past the unfortunate wardrobe
that looked less Emma Frost and more Fembot
from Austin Powers but when a character seems
to breathe more life on the pages of a comic
than with a living person acting out the character,
there is little that can be done.
January Jones may be be stunning but her performance
as The White Queen is far from royal.
Keanu Reeves, Dangerous Liaisons
As likable as Keanu Reeves seems as a person,
the guy has supplied a wealth of bad acting
performances.
His “Whoa” persona may combine his stilted
acting with his general confusion but there
is still something appealing about him.
While many point to his performances in Bram
Stoker’s Dracula, or even The Matrix, the
performance that really interrupts an otherwise
fantastic film is Dangerous Liaisons.
His role does not require as much screen time
as Glenn Close, John Malkovich, or Michelle
Pfeiffer, and that is a good thing.
It is a quiet, yet startled, performance that
attempts seriousness while trying to keep
up with a cast of seasoned thespians.
Reeves’s performance may be what Ashton
Kutcher studies when trying to prove to people
that he is not just some fool who has to bite
his lip to avoid saying “Dude”, when he
plays pretend
Jaden Smith, After Earth
Nepotism in Hollywood may work in the case
of Kate Hudson, Gwyneth Paltrow, and Liv Tyler
but when it doesn’t work, it fails miserably.
Jaden Smith’s performance in After Earth
is proof that talent is not always genetic.
As the son of the Fresh Prince himself, Will
Smith, Jaden made his debut as Will’s son
in The Pursuit of Happyness which required
little acting, The Karate Kid remake was a
slap in the face for those who grew up in
the 80s, and After Earth was just a tragedy.
The science fiction film was a box office
hit which is all thanks to his actual movie
star father, but Jaden’s presence in the
film ruins any possibility of the film succeeding
on any level.
Poor Will continues to push for his children
to work in the industry.
It must be true that Parents Just Don’t
Understand.
There you have it.
What do you think of our list?
Who did we forget?
Let us know in the comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel to see more videos like this
one